[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
another exciting episode of honest
trailers commentaries
this week gi joes uno and dos
um i'm here with lon harris uh just just
two joes today
uh uh minus joestar
one and two it's america counting none
of this none of this mexico
counting yeah this is a real amount well
but it's actually a multi-international
kind of a deep state thing
we'll get into it we're gonna watch um
we're gonna watch gi joe
the honest trailer give your behind the
scenes thoughts show you some deleted
scenes
uh respond to comments and questions
from viewers like you so keep them
coming in the chat and they'll tease you
with next week's honest trailer
probably the one you were hoping for but
it takes us a little longer to get
it yeah whatever we're celebrating the
release of snake guys okay
[Laughter]
a few weeks ago a week or two ago now
it's already ancient history
um i'm also wearing uh fandom's new hat
logo phantom's new logo on a hat uh so
you might notice a few different
little graphical tweaks around these uh
sites um
and uh i don't know if you can buy this
or uh or just
send me uh 20 bucks on cash app and i
will send you this hat
uh that's that's a promise
yeah yeah uh so yeah we'll do a swag
swag box
unboxing it's it's like strewn on my
couch back there later if that's the
kind of
content you crave but for now we're
going to talk about gi joe
two movies i had i had purposefully
avoided because i heard they were bad
they looked dumb but then
i knew i'd have to watch it for work
eventually and here we are the days come
uh they were silly i kind of liked the
first one
in a very dumb uh like kid playing with
their toys kind of way it really did
feel like they filmed a nine-year-old
playing with his gi joes and just
transcribed everything he said or did
because
and now the baroness shows up in a
helicopter and shoots snake eyes and
snake eyes fights back with this
like it had the logic of a kid playing
with toys
and then the second one just seemed like
they were trying to ground it more and
make it a little
bit more real and they kind of had a
good thing going with channing in the
rock but then he
bounces after 10 minutes it was a mess
uh lon what do you feel about the whole
franchise well that's what's weird is i
feel like the story
like among people they the the word on
the street is that the second one is the
superior
film but i don't feel that way at all
especially after revisiting them
the first one is i mean crazy and dumb
and it kind of does the pat and oswell
thing of like oh you like cobra
commander well
this is about him when he's just a
regular guy
like you know it's like why do i want to
see that just like it should start and
he's already
cobra commander like what's that we
don't need a it's it's so weird that all
of these movies kind of go including
snake eyes
it's so weird that they're always like
show us the beginning of you you need to
know that cobra commander is is duke's
stepbrother
yeah it's exactly like x-men in this way
where the movies are always like before
they were the x-men
they were just these eight morons and
it's like i don't skip that part i don't
care like open with them and they're
already
the x-men and i feel the same way like
this should just be joe's going on a
mission and they're
already the joe's i don't i don't care
about the leader the first one is very
much that and
like they just keep throwing joes at you
like they just keep popping out of the
woodwork
it feels like you're getting like these
two guys are sort of sucked into the
world of joe's that pre-exists
and you've got dennis quaid and you've
got all of these various people
and none of them have very much to do
they all just kind of stand around but
at least it
like it does feel like the world of gi
joe already is happening and there are
fights and
weapons and toys and whatever yeah yeah
the second one is just oddly like it
can't decide if it's just a war
movie or if it's a gi joe crazy
over the top sci-fi spectacle thing and
it kind of tries to weirdly straddle
the the third act it kind of is like ah
forget it
yeah and i thought they were actually
off to a good start like they there was
kind of a good
chemistry between channing tatum and the
rock it's like okay it's like a buddy
action movie
and like right you have to forget the
the continuity like the beginning of
part two makes no sense
in part one channing tatum tatum's brand
new to the world of gi joe
and his best friend does marlon way it's
and then in part two marlawynne's
gone unanimously removed
ja rule fast and furious style just
never
[ __ ] again and uh and but channing tatum
is pretending that he's like
lifelong friends with roadblock now
played by dwayne the rock johnson who
we've never seen before
and like presumably they just met
because the the timeline doesn't make
sense because
so uh zartan has been posing as the
president
that whole time like zarta was already
posing against the president
before chatting multiple times so how
many terms is he serving he's already
uncle duke how does that timeline work
out explain it to me
yeah yeah the the other just overall
thing that i don't know
if we really get into is just like maybe
it's just because i'm watching this on a
small screen but the action
has not held up well i mean i feel like
that when they get the robot suits and
that chase is
okay but everything really looks like a
playstation
2 to be charitable cutscene i agree
except i think there's
one very notable exception and it is in
retaliation
the uh escape with storm shadows
uh unconscious body from oh yeah
monastery where they're swinging away
from the other digits
that part is legitimately cool and i
feel like
that part was like that's where the idea
for snake eyes
came from was like that's obviously the
best part why don't we just make the
movie about that guy
yeah but then they were like but maybe
it should be an origin again it's like
no
we left three movies about the history
of snake eyes and storm shadow and it's
like they were friends and then they
fought
if you have to make a snake eyes movie
the entire thing should be about him
trying to get
up a cliff with other ninjas trying to
not let him do that yeah that's all you
need right
it's like the raid but a cliff instead
of in a building
yeah anyways there's plenty more to say
i'm sure
uh let's watch i also like one more
thing they gave the entire backstory in
retaliation
to rizza that's the guy you want now but
for some reason he's the one who tells
us the entire history of snake eyes and
story which we already got in
in rise of cobra which is just a
flashback of two children
beating the ever loving child yeah
let's play we'll get to that part
[Music]
from the company behind all the worst
toy stories
comes the exciting prologue to the gi
joe franchise
and also the other exciting prologue to
the gi joe franchise
after that first one didn't hit because
after two films showing us how it all
began
it's time for the joe verse 2 yet
another exciting prologue
again knowing is half the battle the
other half is knowing when the
battle is supposed to start as
disgusting
remember the classic gi joe cartoon and
action figures
kind of before your time okay well they
made two movies about the guys from the
pork chop sandwiches video
pork chop sandwiches us i mean that
is the most uh that's
that's got to be the gi joe cultural
peak within the last 10 years right more
so than the movies
spencer films i always like uh i don't i
don't have a good sense for this like
when we were talking about space jam 2
originally i was like
how do kids today do they know looney
tunes like i feel like that's out of
touch and then people were like
no you idiot you complete [ __ ] the
looney tunes were on cartoon network
recently and had a popular show
so i don't know maybe maybe there's a
new gi joe thing that has brought
younger generations on board it does
seem like
there must be newer toys that kids are
in but yeah hasbro's other toys
i mean i know they have uh they've got
transformers
well sure and that's those remain
popular like the kids still like
transport
yeah they've got the power rangers so
they've tried their
also still popular you know like an
ongoing franchise
rom the space night that sounds sweet oh
yeah
i remember i remember him they've got
furby how is there no furby movie
um i'm sure all of these things are in
the works
and are they also stretch armstrong
isn't that always a thing you hear about
every few years there's going to be a
stretch
yep they got that they got beyblade they
got uh
nerf this just makes me wanna play with
toys that's way more fun than watching
uh
this movie movies based on toys well
yeah that's like the design to be done
but i don't know i feel like they're
over complicated i feel like g.i joe
of all of these franchises we mentioned
is probably the one that's the most
movie ready like you got to kind of
thread the needle of it's
military war stuff but you want it to be
okay for kids
which they don't really do with these
movies they just make them violent and
they're like ah
they're pretty violent but um but other
than that it's like well that's easy
they're just like a military group and
they do
they fight this terrorist organization
and you just
tell children not to touch they tell
children not to touch down power lines
like right like don't talk to strangers
unless they're members of the gi joe
and then it's okay they just offer you a
body massage
yeah and they're like team america but
without the jokes
[Music]
also before your time well i don't know
what to tell you then
a serpentor in fortnight but with the
same company as the transformers toys
behind the project
they're gonna follow that same old
formula mixing generic military dudes
and hot military babes with a bunch of
cgi nonsense
yet it never really comes together see
michael bay knew that the secret sauce
was racist robots what are we gonna do
with this shrimp tacos
i do not mean mudflap i do
weighs two hours i wonder how many times
they've used that clip dude
performance with all the easy going
charm of a man who's there against his
wife
because he was i hate that movie i so i
was pushed into doing that movie
he's playing a sad potato it's kind of a
fascinating uh
backstory i don't know if it's sad but
it's just like
uh channing tatum you know he's a
breakout star and he signs like a three
picture deal with uh whoever made this
paramount something like that that
sounds right yeah
yeah and it's like uh you know
like okay here's your second movie with
us um
it's called it's gi joe and and the
script sucks but you have to do it
because you signed up for three movies
you're duke now you're dupe now i don't
want to do this movies like sorry
you signed up for three generic movies
that we want to make and this is the one
we want to make
um but why would the studio want to do
that like why would they
put somebody in a movie that doesn't
want to be there yeah i
i don't i don't know i mean i think this
is we've seen it
so much more like there were there was
just this whole debate the other day
about
iron man and there was that there was
that tweet about like any could anybody
have played iron man and
i think increasingly we're seeing
studios just yeah they think of actors
as just pawns like
there are here are my pieces and i plug
them into these projects and
the brands or the the stars so i don't
even think they're thinking about
is channing tatum like right for the
role or he's like a big burly guy who
looks like he could be in the military
we want to make this military movie like
that piece goes there
it may not have been any any deeper than
that no it wasn't any deeper than that
you can tell immediately like he's he's
a good actor in a lot of movies but he
is not good at acting like he wants to
be in this movie
like he it's obvious for a minute what
like we saw that that i
i made that note of 10 huh like that's
not how the
guy in the military says attend gives a
yeah a more convincing military
performance in
magic mike yeah right they all strip in
the uncle sam costumes
yeah i mean it's just ridiculous it's
like if you can't get anything out of
him it's not worth putting him together
just because he looks right you know
yeah it's too bad because like i feel
like other actors though because he has
it
in him to be charming and like a good
action hero and stuff like that that
like
he wouldn't just make the best of it be
like all right i'm going to nick cage
i'm going to give it my all in this
i do get that it's there there is not a
character there
they've done this very weird thing in
the first movie where they've made
duke instead of a character he's like
the hub at the center the entire gi joe
universe oddly revolves around this
guy like he was
uh he used to date baroness the woman
who becomes baroness
uh her brother who was his best friend
becomes cobra commander like it's like
all these weird personal connections
and then only to dump him entirely in
the second movie
so it's pointless but it's it's just
it's that
instead of him actually getting a person
out and even as a character that would
be
he has no no real loyalty or backstory
save for his relationship with baroness
because like i don't know he's a he's a
career
military guy probably of a hardened
patriot or something like that and he
goes into like an underground
james bond base under the pyramids and
he's like all right see a u.s military
i'm joining up with these guys
yeah there's there's no right there's no
inner
life there and i'm sure as an actor
that's what was frustrating to him it's
just like
i'm just constantly reacting to people
explaining their connection to me
which is not an interesting thing to
play it's just like when we just
realized
when we meet him he's telling marlon
wayne's like you can't even leave the
army for the air force like that's a
cowardly move and he leaves
the american military for this
international
uh underground force this pseudo-legal
like we never really like
under whose auspices are the joes
serving the president but they're like
the
the u.s president but they're based in
egypt and they just and they get
arrested by
the french police and then the second
movie introduces the idea that
they were founded by a still active
general played by bruce willis
who was just some piercing just to have
been some guy like why
why is this entire unit named after we
never even get an
answer yeah it's just like he was the
first joe
all right careful they're going to make
another prequel out of that
all right keep going it'll be the john
mcclane prequel and
the gi joe said potato who ghosted his
fiance after getting her little brother
killed yet we're still
supposed to like him later
for too long because he's only in the
sequel for 10 minutes before he hands it
off to his oldest pal the rock
uncle duke wait wasn't his lifelong best
friend marlon wayans what happened to
ripcord
do all the workplace sex harassment
finally catch up with him hmm
i'm attracted to you when i get a target
in my sights
take it down we are tough but we're also
sensitive
watch the rock's reputation when you're
new in the workplace
from grey park and yet another voiceless
role bruce willis doing the least to
collect his check
as is tradition and joseph gordon-levitt
for the first movie at least
as my chemical cobra commander the
inspiration for deadpool
makeup design like a testicle with teeth
ride along with two stories that feel
like they were stolen from a little
boy's notebook margins
featuring twists like bad lady good now
good guy
bad now and uh oh bad guy good guy
in scripts that fail all the way down to
the sentence structure
the g.i joes they're about to be out of
the picture
and by out of the picture i mean
alive on earth that's not what out of
the picture means
did we get that raw like how does that
line make it through
the movie by the way there's a lot of
jonathan price in both of these films
yeah and i don't know a surprising
amount of jonathan price in both of
these films
there's there's i i here's what i think
happened
every character has the same way
of speaking like i don't mean like the
like that they're everybody's got the
same approach which is like i'm super
arrogant i'm extremely
confident and i'm like taunting my
adversary in this really like snarky
bullying way
and this includes good guys like
everybody acts like that towards
everybody else it's just
the good guys are like they have a heart
of gold like they they want the best for
the world they're just personally kind
of a jerk
everybody's talking like a like a
nine-year-old's idea right like a badass
exactly everybody's talking like what a
what a kid's idea of a confident
adult sounds like and so i guess it's
just like
how do you write whole interactions that
just hold that that
beat and that tone the whole time you
end up with lines of dialogue like that
where it's like
wait is that clever i can't even tell
what that character means right there
there's a i always think about the onion
back when they were making like very
insanely well produced uh expensive
videos for youtube
today now interviews the five-year-old
screenwriter of fast and furious
it's just it's just like yeah it it
seems like
it was written by a child and uh yeah
well
all the speeches are like you thought
that's what i was gonna do
it's not in fact even like eight more
planes arrive
you know it's always it's now it's my
turn right
let's fight the same ridiculous stuff
you'd love to see it all right keep
going i think war toys are just for the
boys
so does hasbro but dang it they're going
to do their best to sneak in some ladies
where they can
girl scout to secretary amazing
awkwardly
don't make me shoot a woman get out
nice shoes very awkwardly goodbye
sweetheart
ah that's right you don't kill women
he didn't want to put his life in the
hands of a woman really very awkwardly
amy vanderbort fox of course
that's why you look so fair and balanced
very cute you think it it doesn't
so long as they still promised yeah it's
just this is just a holdover from the
i'm sure the studio saying like we gotta
make another transformers what as
transformers have they got megan fox in
a little pair of shorts
yeah uh yeah it's it's so you could you
you like
feel this ted especially this is more
true i think of cobra the rise of cobra
than retaliation
uh but it's true it's kind of true both
you feel them like
well we can't just not have women like
we have
we'll get in trouble we have to have
some female joes
we have to have some characters for
girls to come get into that
that are heroes and doing badass stuff
so they know they've got to do the right
thing and do it but they don't feel like
right about it like they can't just put
a woman in there and have her fighting
alongside the boy characters as their
equal
that would that would break everybody's
brain so they've got to like make all of
these weird like well maybe they get
harassed or maybe they're in skin-tight
leather the whole time or
maybe the girls only fight the other
girls while the guys work out their
stuff separately
is yeah the guys are constantly in like
a flop sweat like i can't
uh like kill a woman it's just like why
not
like you're in a world that's so
ludicrous anyway like a woman fighting
alongside a man
actually happens in real combat that's
not crazy at all yeah
um yeah a lot of uh a lot of panic uh
behind the scenes so much and it's like
it's total you just don't
you know this is such a ludicrous world
anyway nobody's questioning the
reality just put just just have the
women in there yeah there's a
there's a fighter plane that speaks
welsh in this movie
right that's the sticking point it's
like well we have to deal with the
obvious gender disparity in a combat
situation he's like no you don't
why are you engaging with this at all
you have to engage with the fact that
there is a fighter plane that only
operates if you speak
gaelic to it gaelic yeah because uh
they would have just intuited that
that's christopher eccleston's native
tongue
oh ludicrous the whole thing is so
ridiculous that's another weird thing
there's a lot of here's what we did very
purposefully in part one
and then part two comes in and they're
just like remember that thing for part
one
forget it like it's like in a grandiose
way like destro
they very purposefully set up in part
one christopher eccleston
surprise twist he's destro they even
give him his familiar metal describe why
he's got a metal head yeah
the whole thing they leave him alive
he's in this this cryo prison or
whatever this tank
prison with cobra commander and then as
soon as covert commander gets out he's
just like forget it destroy you're dead
to me
and then like that's it like why even
set that up like i don't
you don't even need christopher
eccleston he's got a metal head you
could put anybody inside the metal head
oh yes you could uh it's like you did it
just to
just to frustrate people who like
continuity in their movies
keep going dress all sexy
and when a fight breaks out only square
off against the other woman
even if that means fighting an old lady
experience two films that can't even do
american propaganda right
where the army keeps getting its ass
handed to them bombs their own troops
and doesn't notice when their own
president gets swapped with a
shapeshifter for months
meanwhile the joes do nothing but get
beat up have their
stolen get arrested and let everyone in
london die
like 9 million people dead sorry big ben
so before you see snake eyes empty yeah
yeah i just i i really if i expected one
thing
uh walking into this like this is going
to be like
u.s imperial military propaganda and
they just
look like complete it was very real in
the sense that they're always blowing
themselves up by accident
and they're just bungling operation
after operation and pissing off the rest
of the world i was like wow
okay yeah they really get they get like
worked
until it's always until the very end
like at the very end they save the day
but they get just like pummeled to the
ground before then in both movies
there's one ray stevenson plays firefly
in retaliation the guy from uh you know
punisher warzone that guy
and he like he gets to kick the rock's
ass in this movie like not just hit him
a few times
like give him a pretty strong beatdown
and he only
the rock only survives that fight
because other people come along and like
they take out firefly for him
he's like down for the count and about
to be shot in the face like
yeah that's that's commitment to the
joe's losing a lot before they win they
lose the eiffel tower
all london and everyone in it um they
uh lose the president to a shapeshifter
for months
an untold number of years uh and then
like the whole thing that sets it off is
like a
botched raid in iran or some some
standard military uh middle eastern
country where they're like they might
have nukes maybe so we're just gonna
invade and do this like smash and grab
and everything goes completely wrong
it's like yeah okay this is
kind of holding up a mirror to us
foreign policy i did not see that coming
from
from gi joe is it pakistan in the
beginning
maybe get where they are yeah they're
like and
somewhere they should not be somewhere
the generals like that place is a is a
mess it's just like basically a step
away from a riot we need to preemptively
uh shoot everyone and grab their face
and then everything goes wrong i can't
believe everything goes wrong from there
but
yeah so there you go um i also like uh
cobra's evil plan
in retaliation is like it's like until
the very end
like most of the plan is just we want to
nuclear disarm the entire world
at the very end they're like so that we
can then take over but up until then
it's like
good maybe cobras got the right idea
weird way they're like grindelwalding
this like you're making some good points
all right keep going or you see snake
eyes empty so before you scroll past
snake eyes on some streaming service
revisit the films that already gave you
a perfectly reasonable snake eyes origin
story
he's a lost member of the wu-tang clan
but in order for me to bring him to
justice
you must deliver him who spent his
entire childhood beating the crap out of
another kid
kid fight kid fight kid fight kid
fight fight kid fight kid fight kid
sadly this is the best part of the whole
franchise
kid fight kid fight kid fight
story i was dying laughing that they
kept cutting back to these two children
beating the crap out of each other
like it was [ __ ] gandalf in the
ballroom
for like 5 000 years it almost feels
like it's a blood sport reference you
know there's that really long montage of
bloodsport where his master keeps like
throwing him to the mat over and over
again like i almost feel like this was a
riff on that
things like endless kids just throwing
each other around
anytime they cut to storm shadow first
he's like spinning his
his ninja star and then like he gets a
far off look in his eye and it
cuts to two children beating the
ever-loving crap out of each other
and they do that like five times in the
first movie yeah and snake
and it worked so well they were like
proof on it they were like that
making a whole movie now it's a whole
movie but just put henry golding in
those scenes
and he's beating up a child seriously
anyways it got me every time because i
was like oh are they still gonna be
fighting
and the answer was always yes um well
it's better and that's the first movie
and in the second movie they just have
rizza
tell us about what happened then it's
like i go back to the kids fighting yeah
yeah let's go back to the good fight
all right keep going keep waiting for
method man to jump in i code
i'm hunting cowboys inventor of the
fidget spinner
the price is wrong dwayne the walk away
from explosions
johnson fight chicks scarjo
my trooper ex-girlfriend the quaid
redemption
we all live in the high-tech submarine
high-tech submarine high-tech submarine
i'm going to sew storm shadows out
shut and just keep feeding him and
feeding him oh i'm sorry
for that brendan fraser for one scene
why and more cisco than the thong song
apparently unknown so one thing's for
sure only minor injuries to report sir
knowing half the battle a lot of cisco
branding oh yeah
body massage origins
wow an exploding motorcycle you have to
jump off of to use
that's probably the worst weapon in
history
yeah consistently there was there was
joe tech that was
worse than things in the real world like
uh the rock has like special gloves that
get really hot to melt
yeah the fence yeah you can just clip it
it's fine it's fine you can cut it
it's weird you you almost expect more
like blatant attempts to sell you toys
like there are a few where they're like
there are a few where they'll be like oh
is that the new and then they'll like
name the vehicle or whatever
you could tell that's obviously the name
of the toy you know yeah but like
there's not that much and a lot of they
don't do a lot visually to make the toys
look
awesome like i kept waiting for scenes
where they're like they're gonna get on
the boat you're gonna see how it like
moves around and looks cool and
it's like they really don't do a lot of
that most of it just looks kind of
generic
metallic the little the little laser
boats at the end look very like episode
three
kind of dogfight-ish but otherwise it
looked like
regular tanks and yeah it all kind of
looks like there's a there's a weirdly
generic
vibe when you expect the opposite like
yeah you
one thing you expect is like big
colorful showy vehicles like
the the the second teenage mutant ninja
turtles movie out of the shadows
when they introduce the turtle van it's
like
you can tell they're like we're gonna
sell a million of these bands which is
wait just wait
these kids aren't gonna know what to do
with themselves uh and there isn't there
isn't that i kept waiting for that
sequence and
because it would be fun to make fun of
but it doesn't happen yeah
uh just going back through my notes on
these movies walton goggins he he
he's in this he he's trying he's very
good at the one kind of dialogue
everyone gets like i feel like
the the gi joe dialogue as written where
it's like
i'm like a cocky piece of crap you know
like i'm kind of
funny but i i know how funny i am and uh
you know uh
like he's very at home in that zone so
it's a it's a piece of casting that
works well
yeah all right um let's see
some deleted scenes what do we cut out
of this one that's not what out of the
picture means
the ice packs coming down i'm sorry the
ice packs coming down
what you're saying the ice is sinking in
water i want you to go home and think
about what you just said
starring tragic mike
duke fluke my name is duke silent but
violet
then chug off the definitely got high
for this barrow
president evil blockers hobbs and y'all
planes weigh-ins and automobiles blade
it was miss scarlet with a laser gun in
the laboratory say yes to the barodus
atomic former blonde dollar general
cash rules everything around miyagi
rizzo's
al ghul banen gain dr
evil super troopers
goof troop
uh can we get a wellness check on bruce
willis i don't think a guy that sad
should have a house made of guns
open up that couch
what a weird scene that is that whole
scene is so weird yeah it's odd like
he's a retired general
just living in like suburbia why does he
think he needs grenades in his fruit
bowl
well because he's clearly got ptsd and
thinks that the war's still going i mean
it it's
the way that scene escalates is like
okay he's got like a hidden
gun locker sure but then as he bought if
he was like i still keep some guns
around the house like in my garage or
whatever
like that i could buy but like the whole
house having like like
he's waiting for any moment people are
gonna cut does he think he's
it's just it's just funny the way it
progresses from like hidden
secret guns to like okay there's guns in
every cabinet to like okay the apple is
now a gun and
it's like it's like pee-wee's look over
there i'm now a gun
yeah everything is a gun like it's just
like instead of the furniture all being
alive it's just everything's made of
guns
oh good times good times it's like this
cake with everything on the internet is
cake it's like that
except guns like ah entire house
becomes a gun yeah uh thank you guys for
watching
uh please like please subscribe uh click
all the little dingles and dongles
all around this video and you'll never
miss another one because we will be back
for another episode
after we do these uh comments and
questions from you guys keep coming in
the chat
adam holbert writes hearing how uh
channing tatum hated being in the first
movie what actor would you save
for being in a terrible film anyone you
would pull out of a film like you don't
have to do this man
it's okay hey
i mean i don't know a lot like sometimes
good actors showing up at terrible
movies
is like that's the fun that's the fun
part like i wouldn't
rob myself of that experience yeah like
there were so many good actors at
gunpowder milkshake did you watch that
on netflix
not yet it's not i didn't like it very
much but the only thing that's fun about
it is the actors are in there having a
good time so i don't
i wouldn't rob michelle gao of that
experience or michelle yo
i'll show you yeah yeah i don't know i'd
uh
gosh i mean halle berry and pull her out
of catwoman
you know she doesn't have to do that
it's okay but then she had her great
razzie moment she would lose uh her
historic
accepting her own razzie award that's
true that's a good point
yeah yeah it's fun when uh when actors
have to do
um terrible films yeah yeah let us have
this
let us have this one yeah um
one more uh well several more fan
questions coming up but ryan has
helpfully reminded me um
do you like watching things along with
us clearly you do because you're
watching this show
and uh this friday we're all gonna watch
the uh suicide squad together friday
afternoon
um that's the suicide suicide james guns
the suicide squad so you uh if you were
around for the snyder cut one you know
the drill we'll we'll have some fun
during it and we will all press play at
the same time
and uh and and have us on as well and
we'll be like a
uh unprepared commentary track um
watching all along so if you're not
gonna see it uh in theaters or with a
friend
uh watch it with us or if you saw it
thursday night in theaters and you want
to revisit it there you don't mind
people talking
this would be perfect perfect perfect
perfect uh
okay let's see um max taylor asks what's
the most used clip you've ever done
uh it's gotta be alan right if that
counts yeah
the the allen raptor from jurassic park
three
popped up in so many classic the circle
shot of the avengers is in like every
event i i believe and brian i i thought
of this and then ryan posted the chat
this is katana she's got my back he's
also made numerous
numerous uh appearances yeah hunka hunka
as well
yeah yes that's right that's multiple a
or a or cut uh suicides
no those i'm sorry the warner brothers
cut not the a or yeah
um let's see this one's tough uh evan j
pretzel asked what movie funeral
set in the rain is actually good there
are a lot
i don't know they all blend together so
i guess they're they're kind of
awash funeral set in the rain i can't
think specifically
it's just so cliche like i don't know
trying to think of any
good new movie funeral scene watchman
has that
has that one that i'm sure it does to go
to go to snyder
immediately as one always does yeah
um okay louise valenzuela asked would
the snake guys movie have been better
with kid fights yes
in fact i mean i haven't seen the steak
as standalone movie but
yes it would be better with with more i
mean maybe it has them have you seen it
once i like it
no i wouldn't be surprised if he flashed
back to himself fighting storm shadow as
a child
there's no there's i can say that
without spoiling too much there's not a
lot of kid fights i would say
it's a kid fight uh lackey
what a shame yeah really losing the
heart and soul of the formula right
there that's the whole franchise
yeah uh let's see pat mcgona asks what's
the best tv or film adaptation of an
80s toy what else do we have out there i
mean there's transformers
he says transformers the motion picture
yeah
or no he says sorry i i got that
abbreviation wrong the masters of the
universe show
um oh the tv the filmation show he-man
and the masters of the universe
uh you know what i really like that
cartoon uh the real ghostbusters you
remember that one
yeah i guess those were those were sort
of based on the ghostbuster
toys weren't they i know they had a toy
line i don't know if they were based on
the toys or they were based on the movie
and then the toys were based on the
cartoon show
yeah i don't know yeah i mean there's
been some
i like the power rangers reboot that's
pretty good um
[Music]
bumblebee if you count that for
transformers uh yeah
really not a lot of great toy inspired
movies
choices i mean we don't have compelling
backstories my little pony you know it's
the point is the kid they want you to
come up with the backstory
yeah yeah my little pony friendship is
magic you know whether you love it or
hate it it's definitely
it's it's it's doing it's doing its
thing uh it kind of set the tone for uh
for a whole
generation of cartoons um all right
final question let's see what should we
do here
uh do you want to talk about food or
yourself lawn what would you prefer
oh food food okay
reynard city update channel s uh what
are your tips for eating at a buffet
and i gotta say mine are donuts
in the era of coven are you kidding
don't ever go to a buffet yeah
exactly like i don't know if we'll ever
buffet again right
i mean for me it's it's multiple trips
because
um i back in the days of like you know
when we
uh when we did things like that together
uh
i would say like i go for savory
and then i go for sweet and then i go
for thirds of like whatever i like from
those two
like i i don't try to get the one
massive plate
like because it's a buffet that's the
joy to me is like okay that was a good
plate now i'm gonna go back and see what
else i can find
right this is a personal preference i
don't really have tips though i do think
that people tend to
make the mistake of going for very
filling things early that are
delicious instead of pacing yourself and
like
treating it like it's still a meal like
so you start you know maybe a little
lighter and you build to the
the mac and cheeses the mashed potatoes
the the very heavy dishes and so that
that's what i would say is like
you know wet your appetite by starting
with lighter fare
and then move into the heavier fare over
the course of the buffet meal
yeah i mean this is more of a uh more of
like a fancy
buffet thing but like i'm a sucker for
an omelet bar man
oh yeah how are how are their omelets so
much better than anything you could
possibly make
at home they're just so good and so fast
i think part of it is the
seeing it being prepared you take this
this beat
this moment to become hungry and
anticipate how good the omelet is going
to be
then helps your omelet experience it
does help dramatically
it's true it's like the same thing with
going to a movie theater like
one of the things that is intangible
about it is the moments where you're in
line to buy popcorn
you get you're sitting in your seat it's
getting dark the the
maria menounos is talking at you or
whatever like you're building up your
anticipation you're getting
in the mindset to watch a movie whereas
when you throw something on netflix it's
just on
there's no spectacle to it i think that
matters psychologically
the spectacle does matter you taste with
your eyes um so
there you go you brought it from from
food to movies thank you lon
um that wraps up our time for today uh a
lot of good questions though we'll we'll
get to them next week
um and when we do the following film
it's one that you uh want to see um
but you're gonna have to trust us you're
gonna have to trust us
uh that's a clue for next week uh we
hope you'll be back
um not just for that but for our suicide
squad party
uh this friday um we'll let you know
more as we know more
we'll see you then thanks lon see you
everybody bye
[Music]
you